I'm either gonna go to SoulCycle or get
a peloton bike okay but I've never tried
either but in my head I think do you
like classes no well that's what I hate
and I hate riding on a stationary yeah
so I'm pretty sure I'm on the right
track I'm thinking to get in the peloton
which you can do in your house which is
essentially SoulCycle if you don't want
people to see you know right they have a
screen in front of you that gives you a
course to run but I want to try it like
why should how much does it cost to buy
one of those it's a couple of thousand
oh that's what I mean about 2400 yeah
yeah but why would I spend 2400 on him
something I'm not gonna use it there
like a place you can go and try it out
for a week that's not a peloton busy
also says there's a place you can go and
try it out and not be in front of people
oh really
because I asked my friend about
SoulCycle and he evidently told me that
he sits up front because he's some kind
of SoulCycle expert and if you sit up in
the front you're supposed to inspire the
class so I said well look did I want to
sit in the back it's I think you might
enjoy it because you get to choose that
you get to choose the length that you
want to do you get to choose the kind of
music you want and you get to choose the
kind of workout but on peloton yeah look
if you want to do low-impact but by the
way no offense you're fat so how is it
not working you do it how many times a
day I mean how many times a week I
probably do it four or five times a week
Wow
what are you yelling at Gary he insists
that he won't [ __ ] leave Benjie
[ __ ] leave dude he's trying to talk
all right Benji what do you want to say
I'm a lovely Lance Armstrong another fan
sir oh don't go what do you want to say
well I can't talk here ghek then go home
please nobody asked you well Gil you did
ask me actually I didn't you just said
Benji what do you want to say yeah
because you're annoying game I see on
the camera there that Gary every time
he's talking he's he turns off the mic
and he starts yelling at someone I know
that you're you're pestering him well I
was gonna say that you would like
peloton much better that's what I was
saying no no he didn't Gary you know
about Sakai go to SoulCycle what new
information do you have
well I can't okay SoulCycle you on the
bike oh I heard about that my friend
told me like you stand up and you start
like dancing doing that you could do
anonymously at your house and honestly
so so far you haven't added anything but
you don't know anymore than get him a DJ
good like the Gary I'm talking I'm gonna
conversation Gary and I see he's
distracted yeah he's getting off mic and
yelling at somebody in silence because
Benji did palatov before I did I think
he feels he's the expert but you were
doing just fine I use it a lot and so
every time you would say something to me
he would be next to be going but no but
wait and I was like I got a pinch don't
worry I got it
we don't want what is that what does she
do he's doing stick he's doing stick
based on reality he's past that he can't
be the yeah and why would I take workout
advice from a guy the size of a house